[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win folks in your life
we do that by helping you win with your
money in your work and in your
relationships 8825 5225 is the number to
jump in we'd love to help you today
8825 522 5 I'm Ken Coleman joined by my
dear friend uh the incomparable the
graceful Rachel Cruz ladies and
gentlemen I love all the adjectives
every time you host Ken I appreciate it
like a good adjective uh I also like
helping people out you ready to go let's
do this all right we're to take your
money questions Rachel's going to be
your money expert today we'll take any
work rated bigger shovel questions I'll
help out on that and she always weighs
in on anything I say so it's going to be
fun I promise let's go to Kissa that's a
very interesting name love the names
Kissa from Little Rock Arkansas how can
we
help hey um thanks for thanks for taking
my call um yeah so my question is I work
as a traveling nurse right now um in
traveling I make like probably around
120,000 a year if you average it up
working full-time you know not taking
any too much time off between
contracts um I
would like to um I'm single right now
I'd really like to settle down and have
a family um have children you know
that's really where my heart is um I
don't have like anyone in my life right
now that I would get married to have
children with that's what I want to do
um I'm also paying off debt right now um
I owe like I think a total of less than
um 30 8,000 between student loans and a
truck payment as well um and I'm set to
pay all that off by August um because
I'm putting like
5500 month into that yeah you know I'm
pretty you know I don't spend too much
you know I'm pretty like reasonable with
my finances but like my thought is like
okay should I because I do want to
settle down I do want to have a fam like
should I leave travel nursing after and
and get like a core staff position after
I pay off this debt and then start
working on you know like the 15% into
investing um and saving for a house and
stuff like that or should I keep
traveling make think how intense is the
traveling how much does it affect
you um I mean I I like traveling I enjoy
traveling I make friends really easily
um I guess I just I I'm getting to that
point in my life you know where it's
yeah I don't some more stability I get
that yeah in a sense yeah well the
reason I asked that Kisa is because I'm
curious how much you would make less
because you're makinging 120 as a travel
nurse how much less would you make if
you played out the scenario you asked us
about and now you take a staff position
what would that pay look
like um it depend I mean it depends on
where you live I'm from I'm from
Arkansas um and so I would think
probably if I was to be core staff in a
hospital in Arkansas I'd probably make
I'm guessing like 60,000 okay so here's
I'm I'm curious to know what Rachel
thinks but I I'll jump in really fast
and say just from a professional and
financial standpoint um if the if the
travel nurse is not affecting your
ability to date you know and and and we
I hear you want to settle down makes to
sense but I also didn't hear a person
who's who's feels like their soul is
sucked out of their body because of the
traveling you're like I like the travel
I just want to settle down I want to
have my house I want to have my backyard
I get all that but until we got that you
know that relationship thing going it me
personally I'd keep doing the travel
nurse uh and hey if I'm traveling that
means I get to meet a whole lot of
people and uh hopefully that life
partner and I would be focusing on my
relationships and putting myself out
there it's not a dating advice show but
I would keep stacking the cash Rachel
and then when we find that significant
other uh then we settle down because I
just think that not only can you knock
this debt out really fast I'd love to
see that fully uh funded emergency fund
Rachel and then she gets going what are
your thoughts on that yeah do how old
are you can I ask I'm 29 29 okay um yeah
I mean I think if you're still enjoying
the travel
nursing I mean I would keep doing what
you're enjoying because you're going to
you after the debts paid off like Ken
said and and yes if you have that
emergency fund I feel like that freees
up even more options um for you so I
probably let those be my two goals that
are driving me to stay in the
high-paying job to get through that and
then you're going to look up you know
and be in your early 30s and you may say
gosh I'm just kind of I'm tired of this
right I mean like I'm in my mid-30s and
we have friends that you know he changed
jobs because he was traveling a ton and
he was like I kind of just want to yeah
I don't I'm just tired of it right so so
I do think there gets to a point in your
life that you may not enjoy it as much
anymore and then you're going to have
the freedom financially to be able to
say yeah I'll live them 60 Grand and
settle you know settle down regardless
of having somebody in your life or not
um I would kind of drive my financial
goals to keep me motivated to stay in
that high-paying job and then once
that's
reached um yeah then you're able to say
gosh I I'm good cutting my income in
half because I can and I'm I want to
just settle down more and and be in one
place so um that's probably what I would
do does that
sound around kind of what you're
thinking or um do you want to just like
quit
tomorrow no no I wouldn't you know I
want to like pay off my debt first for
sure um so I'm not going to quit right
now um but you know like I I think it
sounds I think it sounds really
reasonable I guess it and I mean
obviously like I I I believe in God like
I believe that like it's kind of
divinely appointed you know um
partnership and stuff like that but you
know you know as a traveler like you
know you don't necessarily like build
like
longterm
yeah I hear in your voice that you want
to pay this debt off and then you want
to slow down that's what I hear you you
want to you want to pull back from the
traveling you want to establish some
Roots that's what I hear is that what
I'm is that how you felt before you
called us yes Roots I want my roots yes
I I don't have any Roots I I don't have
a problem with that we're not trying to
talk you out of it I guess I think it's
great I think I I would push to get
through baby step uh three which you
just need three I would say three months
of EXP expenses and then yeah and then
settle down but stay stick with this
maybe for another year uh or like you
know map out okay when can I you know
get this paid off and all of it but have
an end date so at least you're looking
towards something because of what you're
really wanting um yes and I'm not one to
give dating advice I haven't dated in 16
17 years but I haven't had been on a
date since 27 years Cloud though I will
never forget we were at a smart
conference and Dr Henry Cloud was saying
like you um even though yes we believe
in a God that orchestrates and knows our
story and all of that it is still our
free will to get out there you got to go
fishing yeah you got to put yourself out
there and so I remember Henry's saying
that he was like you know he talks to
people and they're like well I just go
to my small group do women ask men out
these days Kisa what's your what's I
I've literally been married 25 years I
don't have a clue I don't think so I'm
just asking Kisa what's the play do do
you ask dudes out or you just got to be
what's the how are you going to get a
man what's the what's the strategy she's
going to be her and she's going to be
awesome and some man's going to be like
do what do you ask guys out do women do
this I mean I don't I'm kind of more
traditional you know people ask me out
you know it
goes if you're in Little Rock Arkansas I
don't know's last name but it's pretty
unique and she's got a great salary
great career she's going to be dead free
soon she's smart look up Kissa all the
single guys in Little Rock give her a
call this could be great this is the
Ramy
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian healthc Care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
all right America you can win in your
money you can win in your work and you
can win in your relationships and the
Ramsey show is committed to helping you
do that so excited that you're with us
we're honored my name is Ken Coleman
Rachel Cruz is my co-host and dear
friend joining me in studio today the
phone number is
8825 5225 that's 88255 225 and if if
you've been listening or or watching
just for a small amount of time it's
nerve-wracking a cult we totally get it
we're going to take really good care of
you we're for you and uh we'd love for
you to jump in today and let's get some
let's get some hope based on some
practical steps that you can take to
move forward the Ramy show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for home Services winter is the
perfect time to freshen up your home's
interior with a new coat of paint
five-star painting can paint your walls
and doors even those difficult cabinets
and trim find a locally owned five-star
painting near you at neighborly decom
Ramsey and today's question comes from
Hillary in Wyoming we have had a shift
in our income and our mortgage is now
about half of our take-home pay we bring
home around
5,500 a month and our mortgage is 2,300
we currently are a month behind on the
house and a truck payment which is $683
a month we have another car note and a
tractor payment our $1,000 $100,000 RV
is in the process of being
repossessed uh between the mortgage
utilities groceries Insurance credit
cards and student loans we are at a
deficit of $400 a month oh when do you
just throw in the towel and sell your
home wow um gosh Hillary you'all have a
lot lot of stuff happening I would say I
mean just to answer your original
question the main question when do you
sell your home unless you see your
income going up double and getting back
to where it was meaning if one of you
all has lost your job but you're in the
process of finding one and you think
you'll find one here in the next you
know 30 days 60 days uh but if something
has shifted that you know okay getting
our income back to where it was is
probably not realistic then I would sell
and you know and again you don't want to
be in a rush with something but then
also you guys need to be have a level of
urgency about you with these other
things I mean the truck the other car um
the even the RV and the tractor the
tractor you know if you can stop this
this repossession if you can somehow
sell it I mean it's in the process of it
so maybe it's too late at this point but
anything you can do to not have things
on your record right like like having on
your credit reports because it's going
it's going to ding you in life and we're
not about going and taking out debt but
in general if someone pulls that for a
job or anything like that's they're
going to be able to see um these
elements of your life and so if you're
able to avoid all of this and especially
a foreclosure and that's what I don't
want for you and so I would make the
decision to move again if you don't see
your income doubling anytime soon and
get rid of some of this stuff Hillary
I'm like You guys sell you can't you
can't afford your truck you you can't
afford the tractor you can't afford the
stuff and so selling it is it's going to
be it's going to get you to a more
peaceful place when you don't have all
these payments yes tough stuff before
I'd sell the house though I I'm with
Rachel I I would try to we have a
deficit of 400 a month right now and so
you know if we can get flip that just
flip that yeah my goal would be okay now
we have a margin of 400 then what do we
have to do to make it 800 we have to
make it to make 1,200 all while trying
to get that income back up but one of
the things we need to mention here is we
are in a country right now that has an
unbelievable employment Market we have
3.7 UNP 3.7% unemployment here's what
that means there are part-time jobs gig
economy type jobs that are available and
even if you had a major loss of a job
which sucks and that takes time to fix
sometimes but going out and making 20 25
an hour yes brings a lot of relief short
term that's right right something to
think about getting one or two of those
yes that's right that's right it may not
be the job but it's a job you're making
an income uh the phone number is 88255
225 let's go to Seattle Washington
Olivia is there how can we
help hi um I'm just kind of stuck in a
pickle I'm on step two and our monthly
income is 4,300 a month and I'm not sure
whether or not I should be selling our
truck so we can get rid of the $800 a
month payment
or or I should cut up my credit cards
because my husband is now starting
training and we don't have the money in
our savings to pay for this training but
after the training he would be getting a
significant pay
increase okay walk us through some of
these numbers give Rachel the num so
talk about maybe let's talk about income
first what he's at now and what he's
projected to be
at okay so starting pay right now or his
ending pay in this position is $30 an
hour and that's the max you can go the
starting pay on this new position is 32
to 34 and what's the training going to
cost and the training so far it's
already costed us $1,500 and I had us on
the every dollar budget app so every
dollar was accounted for um and so I had
a like I was thankful that I didn't cut
up my credit card but this morning I was
so distraught that I should have cut up
my credit card and just tried to figure
it out or something yeah you working and
he works he works I am not working I'm a
stay at home mom but he works um mostly
overtime I don't know if you've heard of
like the north SL on Alaska so that 32
an hour is like a significant increase
compared to 30 yeah okay and um how old
are your
kids I have one child and she's two
she's two okay and how much debt do you
guys have left we have total or just a
car uh total 69 okay okay and what is
that in, and what's that in um
177,000 on a credit card 3,000 on
another credit card 5,000 student loan
and then 41,000 on the car how much
41 yeah which is just outrageous oh my
gosh what's that car worth 34 that's
where I'm really struggling it's just
dropping like drastically yeah there's
so many people underwater on cars right
now um but honestly I mean Olivia yeah
that car is is I you guys probably make
$800 a month well and I mean you make
around probably 55,000 a year before
taxes and and I mean 89
89 yeah before
taxes 89 yeah do you have time and I I
very much honor stay at home moms do you
have any kind of time during the week
where you could pick up some part-time
work even if you're doing it from
home I've been looking I'm just having a
hard time coming up with anything I
don't have anyone to watch her and I
don't want to put her in a daycare and
and I've been trying to find something
but I haven't been able to find anything
okay well keep looking be encouraged you
know what your boundaries are there but
any of that will help but I'm glad
you're looking yeah for sure yeah um
yeah yeah I mean the $41,000 car I
mean I yeah I just don't know if I
should sell it that's why I thought yeah
it's just it's just right on that line
and there's a part of me Olivia that
what sucks is you will have to take out
a probably
$7,000 loan uh to make up the difference
but that feels so much better seeing
$7,000 versus 41,000 and it's a car and
you guys I mean you you've been in this
habit and you said it earlier so I'm
going to just repeat back what you said
you know well we just kept the credit
card around something came up and you
know it's going to be good for us so
we're you know the training and all of
it and I understand how you can like
rationally get there but until you guys
make a mindset shift of this is now how
we handle money we don't use debt
regardless of what it's going to bring
to us in the future until you have a
strong line like that Olivia you guys
are going to continue to creep back in
to these habits you really are and so
there's a part of me for the selling the
car it's kind of like shocking the
monkey it's like this like oh my gosh it
just like it it shocks the system of
what you guys have been living in and it
forces you to say okay we are doing we
are literally acting different right now
we are selling a car that we that we
should never have bought in the first
place we're cutting up the credit cards
and we're just saying no and you have to
have that hard line cuz this whole like
wishy-washy way with debt it's going to
find its way back in and you guys will
look up and the habits haven't really
changed and so um having that hard line
I think is what I really want for you
guys so yeah I would sell the car Olivia
I would start working um to pay off that
credit card uh next the student loan
then the $7,000 the $7,000 loan that
you'll take out for the remaining of the
car yep and and then you guys go and
attack this big credit card debt of
$117,000 and get rid of them I mean I I
I just I um again when we have the
ability to go back in it's the easiest
way in the moment it's okay we'll just
we'll just swipe it we'll just go back
in that's what people find and when you
don't have that option anymore it forces
you to look at other options which there
are other options out there it may take
more patience but there's other options
thanks for the call Olivia you got this
Focus this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me the phone
number is
8825 5225
8825 5225 taking your questions let's go
to Zella who is on the line in
Indianapolis Indiana Zella how can we
help hi hi they Ken um so my question is
my husband and I do not live in the same
country um he's in Canada I'm here in
the us and we're on we're on board with
combining finances with married couples
and take taking down debts first not
using credit card and all that um but we
each have our own debts that we bring
when we got married we're on baby step
two which is paying off the debt in the
snowball method um my question is is do
we tackle our debts in combination like
do we list it from small to big like his
debt and my debt in Canadian dollars and
US Dollars combined or do I send him
money a money transfer and does he send
him send me money transfer um to pay
that or do we tackle our debts
separately okay and we're not combining
our checking account yet because we we
don't we haven't found a bank that would
accept both currencies yet all right
couple questions before we dive into
that part um how long you've been
married six months now and and the plan
was to to live separately the entire
time no we are currently working on
getting him here to the us we actually
have our application now and it's in
process um in the immigration USCIS it
just takes a while about a year or two
even though you're married even though
he married an American woman it's still
taking about a year I'm not an American
citizen yet I'm just a green card holder
over here okay all right that that's why
I was okay gotcha um wow Rachel uh I
don't like that they have not combined
accounts although if you're saying this
is a legal well there's a logistical
thing I think when you're working two
yeah two separate countries I mean yeah
you guys may not find a great solution
to actually share a physical checking
account together um until he comes here
what does he make and what do you make
financially I for him I converted this
the US dollars for his salary is 60k US
Dollars mine is
80k and he has about also 64k of total
loans debts and I have about 19k of
debts okay how long um I'm just curious
how long were you guys how long did
you'all date
for we only officially dated for two
months before we got married but we've
known each other since we were
kindergarten oh okay okay so you guys
have had history so you knew going into
this that you would be in this situation
from a from a longdistance standpoint
you've known each other since
kindergarten so are are you
Canadian no we're both Filipinos we just
migrated to different
countries um at some point in our life
and
we here in the US and okay what country
were you in when you met as
kindergartners the Philippines we both
grew up there and then our families
migrated to different countries so he
goes to Canada and you go to America the
US yeah yeah okay are you sending the
way you asked this question I'm just
curious are you sending money to
him I well right now we are
currently in doubt on whether to pay his
loan first or to pay mine first so I was
sending him a money to pay off the
smallest well I just sent him a 100 this
month it's not constant like just to pay
off his the smallest debt that he has
yeah but but but how much money have you
sent him ballpark since you've been
married uh not much like five just $200
maybe in total okay he yeah it's $200 in
total I guess okay and then this is such
an ignorant question I probably should
know this like your marriage license
like when you guys got married is
it
um like our marriage license is here in
the US is okay okay so when he comes
here okay trying to put all the pieces
together yeah was he on a Visa and to to
be able to come over here and get
married a travel visa no Canadian he's a
Canadian citizen now so Canadian
citizens can come over to the US for six
months at a time so he just did it we we
see each other one week a month um
because that's just how the the Border
allows him to to come okay just one week
at of time well this is complex Rachel
this is a little complex well I mean
there's a reality that yeah if you're in
two separate countries with two separate
currencies yeah you may not be able to
to share a physical checking account I
mean that's obviously the goal once you
guys get into a place that you're
actually living in the same country
that's what we want to work towards but
since you are married you know seeing
this as a holistic picture though that
yeah for you guys combined to look at
your income as one uh I would take all
of your debts and I would combine them
and say okay let's list out the smallest
debt
to the largest and you know when you get
married it is you are you are one in
every aspect of this and so um I would
be paying off yeah the smallest debt
first regardless of if it's his debt or
your debt um and and I'm be yeah and I
and my hesitation when I'm saying all
this is yeah for all of you listening
though you don't do this unless you are
legally married you do not do this if
you are engaged if you are dating um but
for a married couple this is yeah this
is what you do and so uh combining but
yeah I mean in a perfect world you guys
would be able to you know see each
other's accounts and you're very much on
the same page um with your budget and
what he's going to be spending what
you're going to be spending it's just a
really kind of weird situation when said
being in two living in two separate
countries for what could be two years
and you're married I'm like man that's
terrible zel I'm sorry to keep asking I
you said that you guys are on board you
said that we're committed to this
100% both of us so you're seeing
progress you're seeing his budget based
on his
60,000 and so you're sending him the
money for what what was the reason for
sending him money again just to help pay
down the lowest the smallest death yes
so just to help pay down his smallest
death and when it's time for my small
death he he also sends me money so you
got evidence I don't know if that's the
the wisest great so you guys are on the
same page and and we are attacking this
thing as though we have the same account
and we're in the same country it's just
separate so that if you're doing that
then then that's fine um but he's got to
be fully on board 100% on board he is
100% yeah wow very interesting I've
never yeah well keep going listen I know
good luck Max communication like this is
hard yeah wow that's hard I mean dating
long distance is one thing being married
long distance well you think about how
many couples struggle with finances when
they live in the same house yeah I know
yeah so I think yeah just a lot of
communication between you guys um
um yeah
and we you know the reason we would say
you don't combine accounts because there
are reasons there's asteris to this
right if you are in a dangerous
situation if there's abuse if there's an
addiction that's not being addressed if
um you know if there's there's reasons
to protect yourself um then that's what
you need to do right I mean and we've
even said on the show there's some
spouses that will
not uh be on board at all on any level
of the same page as my and they go out
and rack up all this debt on their own
and there gets to a point that like you
even have to you know there's a level to
protect yourself so like always remember
that and so um that's why I even said if
you're not married you don't send people
money because this is just an I mean
they've Mar they they dated for two
months live separate countries and um
yeah you just want to make sure that it
is you know everything is okay yeah I
mean I don't want to play armchair
quarterback but zela if I could have
talked to you six months ago
you know I think I would have said look
you're in America on a green card he's a
Canadian citizen let's think about where
we're living a little bit further let's
let's let's let's play this out here and
let's do what's best for our marriage
causes some stress yeah there just a lot
of Separation here and and I and again
this is fascinating to me uh this is
otherwise a a very nice couple these are
good people and a year and a half for
him to be able to get what paperwork he
needs in light of the fact that we have
people crossing our borders just freely
I just don't understand how the
government can't figure out how to help
people who are trying to know do it the
right way like what paperwork does this
dude have to fill out to be with his
wife it's the government it irritates me
I'm not an anti-government uh rant right
now I just kind of go I hate that you
know yeah totally totally done trying
right way that's right can we fast
forward this please I'm not a bureaucrat
in DC or somebody listening
out listen Zella in all seriousness make
sure you guys are really dialed in you
know to an online group you know get in
a class you guys need that extra
accountability just given the
complexities of your relationship don't
move more of the Ramsey show coming
right
[Music]
up hey guys you know this but I'll say
it anyway college is freaking expensive
and student loans are out of control the
average private student loan debt in
2023 was
$55,000 so if you're in over your head
with private student loan debt don't
beat yourself up look we've all made
mistakes with money in the past what
matters is doing something about it now
so if you're in distress with private
student loans that's private not federal
student loans call Y refi y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay to learn
more about this custom refinancing
option call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show America
thrilled to have you with us we're here
to help you win in your life
specifically with your money in your
work and in your relationships all three
of those areas are really connected and
if you're losing in one of them you
might be losing in all three we want to
help you win I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
joins me this hour the phone number to
jump in is
8825 5225 that's Triple 8 825 5225 all
right so uh those of you interested in
real estate thinking about what your
real estate strategy is going to be Dave
Ramsey's got a brand new quick read out
called the what is it oh real estate the
Ramsay way this is fresh off the press
like I haven't even seen this and uh
look at Dave million dooll smile you
know happy to talk about real estate
he's so happy to talk about real estate
we call these quick GRE these are very
very accessible and uh this is taking
Dave's Decades of experience as real
estate putting it all in one short read
to help you with buying selling and
investing it's only 70 Pages home
ownership is still possible you can turn
that home into your biggest asset it can
be done but you got to do it the right
way so you can get your copy now at
ramseys solutions.com
slore that's Ramsey solutions.com
store all right Kylie's up next in
Dallas Texas Kylie how can we
help hi thank you so much for taking my
call so I was calling in because my
husband and I are at a pretty good stage
in our life where we uh have bought our
second property and we are looking to
build
um there was some circumstances that
happened to cause us to move a little
bit faster on the build than we would
have liked so our first home is
completely paid off uh we just have a
mortgage on the second property that we
bought and um the mortgage on that is
about 310 and we're looking to build a
house with about
$300,000 on that property uh we have a
couple different options and one of
those options was to take out a heof to
cover about $200,000 on our first
property um to cover the cost of the
build because we have about
115 saved up to put towards it so I was
just looking um for some direction we're
really not sure kind of which way to
turn and um what's the end goal what's
the end goal what are you trying to pull
off here so this is essentially kind of
my drain property the second house that
we bought um we're needing to build
because right now my father he is 100%
disabled and it was unexpected so we're
needing to have care for him um we don't
want to put him in a home we want to
keep him with us so that's the reason
for doing the build now cuz he does not
fit in our current home it is too small
and it is not um we've made you know
adjustments as needed but that yeah it's
very admirable you guys yeah for sure so
the the second property is there a house
on it now there's a mobile home on it
which prents some uh struggles to get a
construction loan a lot of people don't
like that and the HELOC they're willing
to just give us without of the red tape
okay why are you keeping the first home
then yeah we're currently living there
um in the first home and we intend to
live there through the build and then
once that build is complete we could
either sell it or keep it as a rental I
prefer to keep it it's in a great
location um and it could rent and give
us some really great uh money how much
could you get for it if you guys sold it
today probably in the range of like
$300,000 oh just enough for what you
need for the new house okay okay Kylie
here's what I would do I would no I
would not go take out a helck I would
not continue to go into debt when you
have an asset like a house now if you
guys had everything paid off and you
were going to be you know you had money
saved to be able to cash flow the build
of the new house and you wanted to keep
this as a rental that would be okay but
you're sitting here and you're trying to
kind of PC Mill all this together where
you could make it pretty simple it's not
it's not going to be the plan you want
but I would I would sell I would go rent
for while I have to while we build so it
maybe a 12 18 month uh rental situation
uh making sure that it's enough room for
your dad and everything right so you
guys will have those parameters uh cash
flow the house as you build and then you
know the the three the 310,000 that's
for the land yeah then you kind of take
that as the mortgage and say okay that's
then what we're going to continue to pay
off and so um I would not go get out of
second you know I would not go get a
helck or you know go around that way but
um that I mean that's personally what I
would do cuz I would not continue to go
deeper in debt if I don't have to and
you're in a situation that yeah you have
a great asset of a home and Y I mean I
would use it to further the cash flow
that you guys will be able to pay this
property down quick and then you have
free you you're completely debt free you
have no mortgage or anything right after
that property is paid off and that's
what we want for you we want you to get
to that point fast and this is the
fastest best way uh to do that and you
know in real estate so hard because I
feel like too the idea of having a
rental passive income like this whole
sounds so exciting and it's great like
we love investing real estate right the
real estate quick ey like we are not
anti-al estate people we are pro real
estate people but doing it in the right
time in the right stage of your life and
and for you guys and here's the other
thing cuz uh I uh Kylie we built a home
in 2018 moved in in
2019 and I'm telling you when you have
cash that you are working with you stay
in budget suddenly it's true the upgrade
of the tile oh this this and this do we
have the money for it I mean it really
gives you this hard and fast rule
because it can be so easy to say okay
we'll just get a little bit more and the
bank will be willing to you know we'll
we'll we'll we'll get maybe $40,000 more
to do some you know you continue to
uptick but this really it's an
accountability thing when you're working
with it and what a gift to be able to do
that I mean that's really um how I would
look at this and and and Kyle I just add
very quickly you said that this second
property that you need for your father
uh I'm glad you can do it and Rachel's
100% right you need to sell the current
home and do what she does here's why uh
you would still you would still owe on
that house and now all of a sudden this
dream property MH uh the whole thing
could become a nightmare if you get
somebody in renting your house and
believe me when something goes wrong
with the roof or the toilets or whatever
they're calling you and all of a sudden
I'm a landlord and you have $600,000 and
you're $600,000 in debt and so I I this
is a no-brainer sell rent Rachel's 100%
right focus on this dream this dream
property that also is going to be a
blessing for your dad in in his time of
need don't muck this up it just doesn't
need to get that complicated because
here's the other thing Rachel that kills
me and people go oh you know we can rent
it and I always love to do the exercise
of okay uh what's the mortgage on the
rental property then they tell me and
what are you going to clear each month
and you know if it could be$ 300 $400
like oh so we're going to take on all
this risk yeah and all this pain in the
butt to be a landlord for what amounts
to $4,800 a year right right right right
and that's assuming you have no expenses
yes that's right that's right so this
idea that I'm going to get her paid off
her specific situ her house was I think
so oh I didn't realize it well
everything else I said is true yes but I
would use the money the point is we
don't wanted to go into debt on the new
prop that's right exactly exactly and
why be a landlord carry debt be a
landlord is the point don't do that
that's right 100% it's crazy uh people
get sucked into that that and it's just
there's so much that can go wrong so
hard y that's nuts all right let's go to
Chandler in Salt Lake City Chandler we
only got about a minute and a half two
minutes what's your
question okay so getting right to the
point I'm a PhD student and I'm studying
the skills to be a high level
quantitative researcher which includes
statistics research methods programming
this kind of thing right um my
particular subfield is Political Science
and criminal justice I also work a
full-time job in an unrelated field
while it's really hard and I have to
maximize my time I'm more than capable
of following through with this my
question is would it be a better time
investment to drop a full-time job and
put that towards my quantitative skill
set in the short term that would put me
in a much less fulfilling and more
difficult financial position but I can
see how it would pay off in the long run
when you say more difficult how are we
talking barely scraping by or just a
little uncomfortable yeah yeah it would
be like barely scraping the student
stien you have no debt do you have cash
you got emergency fund yep full six
months what's the timeline you're the
quantitative guy give it to me fast if
you do this move that we're talking
about how long am I in this
uncomfortable barely making it buy
before it pays off and I'm making more
dough uh the payoff would be about four
to five years I wouldn't do it not for
that too risky man one major life thing
happens and you're whacked and it's just
what do I do and I'm trying to recover
I'd stay in the day job finish the PHD
that's hard too but it has way less risk
and so let's step our way into this new
future stay in the day job do not take
that risk it's not worth it you're
trying to exchange time for a ton of
risk and O I wouldn't do that good hour
Rachel Cruz thanks to Austin our
fearless leader and the guys in the
booth this is the ramsy show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win win in your money
win in your work win in your
relationships phone number is 88255 225
that's 8 8255 225 I'm ran personality
Ken Coleman joined by r personality
Rachel Cruz and we are here together for
you this hour we'd love to help you out
let's get it started oh one of my
favorite cities of the South we're
heading to Savannah Savannah otherwise
known as Savannah but I like to say it
that way you always love a good a good
City accent I just love Savannah's a
great City ebony is there ebony how can
we
help yes thank you for taking my call
how yall doing we're doing great how are
you awesome my question is I am finally
starting to make money and I am trying
to figure out how can I finally become
Financial free I don't have like
anything to my name whatsoever what kind
of money you making now that you're
finally making money what's that
number uh be 32,000 a year what are you
doing a marketing company search cler
for you all okay good and do you see a
path forward with them I'm not I don't
want to get locked in on that but I mean
do you see opportunity for promotion
there um I do see growth with the
company it's actually a good company
great well congratulations that's great
how old are you 36 okay all right good
for you good for you thank you um okay
so we um you know Ramsey we always talk
people through having a really
intentional guided plan because that's
probably one of the best things that you
can do with your money is what you're
calling in for but it is to have
direction right and so um part of that
is saving part of that is getting out of
debts uh investing home ownership like
all of that is at play so right now do
you do you have debt right
now I do okay um I purchase a vehicle I
had to give it back um something
happened to the car and then I have
school debt as well because I dropped
out of school okay how much um how much
do you owe on the
car uh 18,000 18,000 okay did you say
you gave it back though you don't have
it I don't have the car no more what
happened uh a company did a oil change
and it messed up my engine and
unfortunately I could not afford to get
the repairs they were pretty high so I
asked them to pick the vehicle up and
they came to pick it up and they're just
who's
they uh the the car uh I don't want to
say the company that did it but yeah
okay like a Mech like a
mechanic yeah someone I was supposed to
be legit it was a new store and I went
there and they messed it up so that I'm
trying to just figure out really quickly
do you not have any I mean what are we
doing here like you should be
compensated for that they ruined your
car um I didn't know until later on down
the road that I could have done
something it was too
late I that last minute okay but I don't
want I don't want you to have given that
car like I want that car back and you
cuz you own that car and that is an
asset um how much will it take to to fix
it I cannot get that car no more it
was carlot has it and that carlot is no
longer available in my
city okay all right so it's
gone it it's gone it was last year I get
it back do you have another do you have
a car right
now I do not I'm actually in a process
of looking for one but
do it cash yeah yeah and how are you
getting to
work the bus okay great yeah it's
awesome okay well good news I know and I
don't want to keep harping on this card
but it is $188,000 of debt with an asset
that at least if you get and you can't
fix it you could at least sell it for
less and and try to get something out of
it how that happened yeah so we we won't
stay on that cuz I want to continue to
help you but I would go back and kind of
retrace those step 70 because again that
that was in your name unless it was
repossessed you couldn't pay the payment
or something like that happen but
overall if you can find out a way to get
that car back I want that for you just
so you can even just sell it for cheap
and make some money on it um okay and
then you have your student loans and how
much are
those uh 13,000 now okay perfect and any
money
saved no money saved no money saved okay
great okay so what I would do is um I
would figure out okay how can I get
$1,000 quickly that's going to be your
first starting point is to be able to
get that fund and I would probably
honestly do that before you save for a
car I want some cash in the bank that's
just cushion to the side um and again
this may look like um working a
part-time job at night for a little bit
uh you know Finding if you can sell
something I mean like anything that you
can do to get that ,000 and I would do
that as quickly as possible so that
would be the first step I would do then
I would probably say I would I would
start saving for a car I would have a
goal um to get a great used car and to
be able to to pay cash for it and it's
not going to be a pretty car it's not
going to be a great car I'm going to
look up some used cars in Savannah but
it's you yes there you go kvor but it's
going to be the best thing yes is is to
get that point of transportation for
yourself um and then the next goal would
be to start working to to pay this debt
down and pay off the smallest amount
which will be the student loans first um
and and maybe in the meantime with that
happening this will take you some time
right this is this will take some
patience and uh it's not going to happen
overnight in the meantime again I would
I would Circle back with the whole car
thing because if there's any way you can
get this
$18,000 down uh it's only going to it's
only going to be for your benefits um so
I would look into that and then beyond
that ebony you know you want to start
saving up for a fully funded emergency
fund after you're out of debt and then
you can start looking at saving for a
down payment and investing but all that
may be a few years um down the line
which is which is totally okay because
you're you're starting somewhere so
that's the overall plan it's called the
baby steps and um I'm going to have
Christian pick up and give you Financial
Peace University which is our money
course it's seven lessons so you can
watch all the videos really get a basic
knowledge of all of this and every
dollar premium because the next thing I
really want you to do today is sign up
for every dollar premium and start
budgeting so you're going to take this
income that you're making and actually
have a plan for it and within that
you're going to be able to see okay
here's how much I have for groceries
here's what I have um you know for the
you can go down the list and really see
here are my expenses and that's going to
help you save that $1,000 as well cuz
you're going to be able to say you know
I'm going to save x amount a month
towards this thousand and you're going
to really just kind of be on that plan
and so um I'm excited for you it's going
to create new habits and kind of a new
way of looking at money for you but I
think that you're you're at that point I
could even hear it in your voice when
you called in you were like I'm I'm
ready to do something and and I think
it's awesome emotionally drain yes
you're emotionally drained is that
always said yeah I've been crying
because it's it's I feel like I've done
wrong CU I'm 36 I have nothing I feel
really really I'm not going to cry right
now and just feel really bad like I
should be further off as far as
financially and it's just it's it's a
little stressful being you know yep
that's yeah let me just be your friend
though for a second and that's that's a
lot of shame I should have I wished I
have right we all have regrets and we
all no one is perfect with money but I
want you to be able to say okay from
this point forward I can do something
and you're only 36 right people call 56
you can still be a million what you got
you got well I was going to say if you
save about 4500 to 5,000 up you can get
a decent car but I would also say if the
bus is safe and it's convenient I'd keep
stacking cash and one little
encouragement I want to add on to what
Rachel said Ebony you're going to get
through this debt quicker than you
realize and if you start just basic
small investing you're going to be a
millionaire by the time you're
65 I hope you hear that cuz it's true
we're going to guide you you can do it
yeah hold on the line Chris will pick up
and and give you that stuff thanks for
Ramy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show thrilled
to have you with us I'm Ken Coleman
Rachel Cruz joins me we're here for
youle 8825 5225 is the number you got a
money question you got a work qu
question you got a work a relationship
question uh we'll take them all because
they're all interconnected
8825 5225 and is now with us in Salt
Lake City Utah Ann how can we
help hi Ken hi Rachel um wanted to get
your thoughts on a potential kind of big
decision that me and my husband have
that might set us up but uh to give you
a little backstory we're both
35 uh we're kind of at baby step six uh
we don't have any debt we're really just
putting a little bit extra towards the
mortgage at this point we have some
money set aside for the six Monon
savings so kind of just working our way
through we've been listening to you for
about a year so it's been good um I'll
say a lot of yeah a lot of I think our
success is at least my success anyway uh
my mom's pretty smart financially so I
take a lot of her advice uh on this
potential decision though she's not very
much on board so I wanted to get maybe a
third opinion okay well we'll give you
we'll give you our thoughts that's right
I promise you that we don't know what
how much it'll help but go for it all
right give us the scenario oh of course
of course with parents um so right now
we bought and took advantage about three
years ago of the really low interest
rates we bought our home that we have
now um obviously we've made some equity
on it now uh with prices going up we've
bought in a pretty decent area so we
have probably um I think probably about
350 that we could get out of equity if
we were to sell so that's kind of where
we're at right now we owe quite a bit
because obviously we're only a few years
into the mortgage we did go with a third
year which of course I regret now but
that's in the past so um we're kind of
at a standpoint to try and decide to
sell uh you know take quite a bit of
amount out of the equity buy something
for Less in a more rural area which is
something both of you me and my husband
you know are interested in um or stick
with the mortgage at a really really low
interest rate we got a hold of a 2%
interest uh and you know kind of just
stay here and light it out or pay it off
early right um so obviously listening to
a lot of the conversations uh and you
know tips that you guys have I lean
towards you know sell take the equity
take some of our s savings and buy
something where we'd be mortgage free uh
my mom says to stick and you know don't
lose the 2% interest because we'll never
see that again so curious yourself but
okay I'm I'm not going to talk about the
money side all Rachel weigh in on that
but I it sounds to me like you guys want
to live in a rural area that's kind of
the life you want to
lead yeah well that's the noin for sure
we've kind of got a we've kind of got a
hobby Farm going now and so maybe delve
a little more into that um can you get
home right now that's a good question
and can you get what you want for that
400 um so for 350 probably we have about
15 50,000 saved um that's in a high
yield savings um it's kind of just above
your emergency fund that's kind of the
other question is like if we don't do
something with that maybe what should we
do with those funds okay yeah is that
above your emergency fund the
150 uh that includes it so I would say
we we could easily take probably a 100
100 okay so for
$450,000 could you it's amazing could
you get what you want in a r rural area
and where you guys want to live have you
looked at houses out there yes yeah I
have and uh there's there's quite a bit
of availability that um it's a
no-brainer and do what you want to do do
it and financially speaking 2% is worse
than 0% I know so poor mom we're blowing
mom's advice out of the water yeah and
listen an and and this is where we're
the weird people in the space when it
comes to this stuff but we I mean when
you own your home home there is a it's
not even a financial move at that point
it is a true emotional spiritual
something happens when you don't have a
bank in your life there's not a mortgage
company in your life Ford Motor Company
is not your like you don't have other
people in your life it is just you
because how much do you guys make a
year um so I bring in about 75 and my
husband brings in uh 85 is depends on
the bonus that's amazing you're living
where you want de free $160,000 a year
God bless your and if you said like yeah
you know what we really want we probably
need to take out of you know $50,000
$100,000 mortgage I'd say okay I'd say
do that too yeah I'm like because you
want to live there at that point yes
like you know you would be able to
afford that too but if you can just
straight up do this in cash I'm like
that's the dream man like that's what
people that that's what you work towards
is to have nothing and you guys make an
incredible income all day all day I'm
living out oh hey my my Winston would be
running for the hills if I said we could
live in a he would be he'd be like
yeehaw you just back uh you know she's
always been the one to pinch pennies and
you know don't take out credit card
loans and go to school debt free and
stuff me awful little hearing this from
her so that's so funny well and it's
good that your mom you know has such a
positive voice in your life but also in
you're 35y old woman yeah so mom's not
going to agree with everything all the
time and you imagine it doesn't matter
like she doesn't get get a vote right uh
and you and your husband I'm I'm
assuming are on the same page like you
both want to make this move and you guys
are excited about
it absolutely so an an do this but just
imagine imagine 20 years from now you're
talking to to Rachel you see her
somewhere you're talking to a friend and
you go yeah we had this opportunity 20
years ago to buy this this great
property cash uh live where we wanted to
live but you know my mom talked us into
keeping the 2% on this house we have can
you imagine how much you would resent
her does that sound silly to you
yeah it does that's where it's like this
internal back and
forth it's good to get a third party
what do you want to do forget what me
and Rachel think you should do what do
you and your husband want to
do oh for sure I think that's been our
dream I mean we've worked from you know
we've been together 15 years and you
know worked our way through this and
kind of y'all done an incredible job a
leverage in one year of listening to
this and doing this plan I mean you've
you you've made it you made it through
all seven baby steps and cue the Disney
music right it's time for dreams come
true pixie dust let's go it's great an
fascinating all right just have your mom
out for a great dinner right I got new
place yeah I got to ask you a question I
think really hits our broader audience
the influence of family and let's also
throw friends in this bucket you've been
coaching a lot of people for a long time
what are your thoughts on this on to why
as to why we have a hard time allowing
our heart to overcome the influence of
what family members say like the heart's
totally in yeah but then it's like why
do you think that is you know I mean I
think that there's a level of acceptance
we all want and I think for our parents
from a parent to a child relationship I
think a child regardless of age you
still are like isn't that true are you
good you know like so true so you think
it's approval I think there's a level of
approval there I also think you know in
Anne's case her mom sounded very wise
with everything else so she probably
genuinely thinks okay or and believes
because it probably is very true that
she's a really wise person with money so
I am going to take what she says really
seriously but the problem is is when all
of that starts affecting our day-to-day
decisions and our life oh decisions and
and for and and kind of and
parents you're not the like at that
point like yes I understand you're still
their parent but you're not their parent
anymore you have a you have an adult in
your life and you don't get a vote
either right so it's um it's interesting
isn't it and I do think parents there is
something about the relationship I feel
like even with my friends and I can say
this even about my own parents as better
of a job as your kids get older and
especially when they start having
families of their own and you become
more peer like you just enjoy I think
you enjoy each other's company more
versus like I still need to teach you
and I still I'm still being in this role
the kid at the adult kid always ends up
feeling like oh my gosh I remember dad
mom and dad have done they've done a
great job with that they I remember even
coming to Dad about a money question
Winston and I had been married probably
18 months it was about a mutual fund or
something and K he would not give me the
answer he's like what do you what do you
and Winston want to do what are you
going to do wow I was like I have Dave
Ramsey sitting in front of me should I
just call the show and like make up a
name be like this is Sarah from Dallas
should have you SAR yeah he I mean that
he pushed us a lot of like you got to
make your own decisions I think
inquiring minds want to know if you and
Winston were to move out into the to the
wherever rural area yeah what animal
would you not on the property oh do you
have a hard and fast or is there any
animal you'd like to have feel like a
rooster would be tough right yeah waking
you up 3: in the morning yeah what about
you tell you I'd have chickens though
I'd like some goat bring I'd like some
goats I like the little noise that make
what would you not do though cows they
stink this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys ramsy Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switch to
net Suite it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show so
excited to have you with us America I'm
Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me the
phone number is Tri
8825 5225 so Rachel and I were just
talking uh we're going to get to the
phones just a matter of moments but we
were just talking during the break we
love getting out amongst the people uh I
I am a self-fashioned man of the people
and I think you are a woman of the
people whether or not you would ever
refer to yourself as that but I love
being out we love doing hang with you
guys we love doing events and so we're
very excited we're not going anywhere
but we are doing an event you might be
coming here what are we talking about
brand new event called Total Money
Makeover weekend it's May 10 and 11 it's
going to be right here on our campus
just south of Nashville and just God's
Paradise of Franklin Tennessee it's just
fantastic it's a one weekend event
you're going to crash course on
everything we teach about money every
side from the big shovel to getting out
of debt saving investing the whole nine
yards
so no matter what baby step you're on
this is going to light a fire under you
there also be a lot of Q&A so when we're
speaking we're also going to be taking
questions live in the crowd we love that
early bird tickets started just $99 but
this is going to be for a limited time
so if you want to get the best deal on
tickets this is it and the Rams Event
Center by the way brand spank a new only
holds 2400 people so it's limited so get
your tickets now at ramsy solutions.com
events that's ramsy solutions.com events
it's going to be fun yeah it's going be
a great great weekend so come hang out
with us let's do it all right Henry is
up in Las Vegas Henry what's going
on uh hi so my wife and me have about
125 uh in household income 305 in a
mortgage uh about 35 in student loans no
other debt um so we're Foodies we like
to go out and enjoy food um but that's
really our only I guess you could say
Vice um I got my student loans I'm
comfortable with just paying the 420
every month uh she would like us to uh
more aggressively in uh pay off our debt
uh and I kind of agree but at the same
time I don't because I don't want to I
want to I don't want to not live as well
I want to enjoy life you know we have
about I think she has 20 something in
her uh rough I have about 30 35 in my
retirement we're putting
10% um so we're we're doing the the baby
steps and we're going along the way we
have about a 100 in cash 100K in cash so
that's about three years worth of if God
forbid we lose everything we can still
pay all our bills to include the
mortgage uh utilities and food so I
think we're doing good but she wants to
be more aggressive versus I don't and
sort of we're we're at an impact of how
uh you know it's not really about having
one person be right or wrong but it's
about maybe finding a balance right you
know because it's all about balance in a
relationship we're not arguing anything
like that but just trying to that's okay
if you are couples argue we're we're
we're okay with that Rachel and I like
to argue can I argue uh okay Henry
remind uh I missed how much the student
loan payment is or I'm sorry how much
debt total student loans are 35 35,000
okay and is that all the debt you guys
have uh and then the mortgage is 305 and
the house is worth about 365 good for
you guys um Henry I'd pay off the
student loans
today okay with you have
$100,000 in the bank pay it off today
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund now you guys are and then bump up
your investing 5% to 15% of your
household income and you guys are
freaking going to do incredible what are
you paying what's your student loan
payment every month uh 420 you just get
a $420 month raise on top eat with that
yeah that'll buy a nice steak maybe the
tomahawk
yeah let's throw another way because
here the $100,000 though I want to
address that because I I so appreciate
it but the so I so appreciate the
$100,000 but the reason why is that it's
three it's a three-year emergency fund
and and he said in case something
happens for years Henry for 3 years
you'd probably be moved and living off
the land I mean like if it gets to that
point in life that you can't find a job
in 3 years so I'm just saying that it's
an unne it's an unnecessary amount of
emergency funds for that reason and so
use it to your advantage you guys worked
and saved so hard for that I mean it's
incredible so use it to benefit you guys
in the present this takes away all the
questions on your aggression on paying
off debt cuz it's paid off it's paid off
today paid off and then get a nice
bottle of champagne tonight and
celebrate you're def I love that and the
Tom H that's amazing uh but but Henry
let me throw something out you here what
if you invested that $420 a month you're
a real safety guy and you're a numbers
guy is this
true yeah she's the more aggressive one
hold second what yeah but what if you
did what Rachel said and you you well no
you said pay off the loan but he's still
going to have uh my math 65,000 okay so
so Henry what if you had
$65,000 in the bank okay and you had no
debt other than your home and you were
able to invest $420 a month starting
tomorrow extra how yeah extra how
exciting is
that yeah with uh you know by the time
we retire will definitely be
millionaires dude oh Henry that's not
even up for vote so your your
cautionary U this cautionary n narrative
is actually holding you back and I'm
trying to flip your brain on this you're
going oh my gosh I don't want to give up
35,000 and I'm going you're not giving
up 35,000 you are creating total freedom
you're freeing up $420 a month to invest
do whatever you want I mean this is a
no-brainer for you and you're still safe
trust me 655,000 in your emergency fund
Henry is plenty for you you know how I
know this because if you were to get
laid off tomorrow you would be getting a
job as fast as you possibly could you
are not a guy who likes
risk correct so what are you gonna do
Henry it's your life did we convince
you uh you're you've inched closer I
don't want to lie to people and say Yes
100% but what are you so afraid
of so I'm afraid of us getting into a
bad situation and my wife craves
stability what would be the bad
situation this is really fun not making
fun of you what's the bad situation
describe it we both most you know well
she already lost her job it's been about
9 months so that's creating a stress for
her and you know God forbid I lose my
job I'm the stable one right now um if
we lose that that 65 can go real quick
wait a second wait wait wait wait wait
what has kept her from getting a job for
nine
months is in the industry of recruiting
it's a little bit difficult right now
okay has she been doing any work oh she
yeah she has part-time work so she has
income okay here's my point this is what
I want to say if that were to happen to
you right now you would go get a
full-time job or you would get a
part-time job or another part-time job
and I would say she needs to get another
part-time job right now she actually
doesn't have to because you're in such
great financial shape and you can live
off your income but my point is I'm
trying to play this out for you Henry
that let's say both of you L your job
lose your job you could still not touch
that emergency fund if you went and got
busy you may have to use some of it but
you're not going to blow through
65,000
yeah that be you guys just sitting at
home doing nothing literally not even
trying to
work yeah that's not going to happen so
I'm trying to walk you up to the
threshold of hell here and you look over
and go what has to happen I love you
because I feel like we're usually the
ones telling people to like slow down
we're the conservative
ones I don't want to pay that debt off
you guys are crazy we're so aggressive
we're the we're the aggressive ones that
never happens really never does but uh I
but listen um here's what's great about
Henry he's never going to make a dumb
Financial move no no so it's now just
building up here here's my thing too the
way you guys live and your ability to
save what you guys want to do pay it off
and if you really keep losing sleep at
night over that 35,000 then just build
it back up well okay I love this great
advice so let's take the four what was
it four 20 let's round it down to four
to make easy math okay over the course
of 12 months that's
$4,800 but just just taking that loan
payment and putting it into savings you
could do way more with the 420 obviously
but you're fine yep H I would be so
happy to get rid of that student loan
it'd be a party I like the champagne
idea yeah thanks and maybe the tomahawk
is a little too much red meat I don't
know but
something go celebrate are debt free
you got to cut the check first Henry get
yourself a peps at AC it'll help this is
the Ramy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show so
excited to have you with us america8 825
5225 is the number I'm Ken Coleman
Rachel Cruz joins me and we're here for
you Ryan is up in Raleigh North Carolina
Ryan how can we
help hey Ken hey Rachel how you it's
good to talk to you good to talk to you
what's up uh thanks uh so my wife and I
have been followers of yours for years
and I have a question about retirement
that I don't know if I've ever heard you
answer okay um but between the two of us
we make about 280 base and then up above
300 with bonuses um and that's pretty
recent that our income is got that high
so for the past couple years we've had
to uh transfer what we were putting into
a Roth Ira just into a regular Ira
because our income was too high for the
limits um and I was wondering if we
should start forgoing the IRA Al
together and just maxing out our WTH
401ks well you can do a back you can do
a backdoor Roth IRA do you know that
right but we yes but we're not at baby
step seven yet no but but instead of
take extra instead of a yeah yeah inad
of putting towards the taxes and instead
of putting it towards the
mortgage wait say that
again so I didn't want to take the extra
money that because if we do the back
door Rock then we have to pay the taxes
that are due on it sure right away
correct uh in doing well you converted
baby step seven yeah baby step or five
five I guess six the mortgage um so
that's why I'm kind of wondering if it
would be better to just because we're
very happy with our 41 K options
percentage okay what percentage does it
get to if you got if you guys both max
out your Roth 401ks what percentage of
your income would that
be like will you will you hit that will
you hit that 15% about well I think it's
225 so it's about 45,000 which is almost
exactly 15% for us yeah okay and then
how much do you have saved total in your
401ks uh um so our total retirement is
probably around
500 yeah but I'm asking specifically I'm
going somewhere with this how much do
you have of that 500 between the two of
you is in your 401ks the Roth
401ks um I think our
401K is
probably
uh
250 here's why I'm asking that question
do you uh work with a smart Vestor
Pro yes okay when was the last time you
met with them about the
strategy uh it's I actually was just
talking with him about you know
transferring over our Roth IRA to a
normal Ira uh because our income
exceeded the limit but I didn't ask him
about this
so what you I'm wondering if it's just
like this is this is real high level
math here Ryan but if you guys are
making 300,000 a year then you should be
investing over
$30,000 um together household income and
in that I mean the max I think is
$23,000 for your 401k Max Roth is 7,000
so that's right ATD I mean you guys
could both you could max out both of
these accounts and do the back door Roth
yeah you pay taxes on it but I would go
ahead and just do that because of with
you're still within the within the 15%
of your income into retirement 15% for
both of us would be
45 45,000 we can each we can do
225 each into 401ks yes I'm I'm gonna
throw out to talk to exactly to our 15%
that gets you to your 15% right which is
why if I can jump in here I would like
for you to talk to your smartvestor pro
about do we diversify because you've got
a good chunk in Roth I'm just wondering
not recommending I'm wondering if it
wouldn't be a good idea to do a joint
brokerage account here gives you some
other tax options and you can invest
that since you've got so much Roth
invested yeah do you start to diversify
that it would be a question that I would
ask yeah yeah but but I'm saying I think
they can still do both they might be
yeah yeah I'm just throwing it out there
that like because the point my goal for
you guys Ryan would be to max out the
401K max out the Roth by doing the back
door and then you have something above
and beyond that then that's when I would
diversification there so because it does
give you now our raw 401K get it's
exactly to our 15% yeah like we wouldn't
need to do an IRA at all oh oh oh what
been say so he's already there which is
why I'm bring if we should do
all yes I probably would at that point
yeah yep okay ining with the match beats
Roth beats traditional so when you look
at that if you have the Roth
401k you could and if your income goes
up though Ryan I would look at the back
door Roth um if your income grows yeah
and you guys have more percentages
because it's just a great vehicle and
and I don't know I don't not I mean I
have no reason to say this I just have a
hunch in life I'm like I don't know how
long that I don't know if they'll have
that forever and ever amen like I don't
know it's just a it's such a great easy
retirement vehicle to throw some money
in how much you guys have left to pay on
the
house about 300 okay it's worth about
750 so awesome great job done in seven
to eight years probably yeah that's
awesome yeah so I would yeah go ahead
and do that and then obviously if
something changes with jobs or whatever
it may be um then you would move yeah
that 401k into just a traditional yeah
Ira at that point but that's obviously
not the hopefully won't happen so sorry
Ryan I was getting mixed up with with my
numbers in my head so yeah I would I
would go ahead and do your 15% all in
the uh Roth 401k now for everyone else
out there the only reason I say that is
because it is a Roth
um we all you know Roth is a beautiful
thing so if you just have a traditional
401K at your job you go up to the match
up to that 3 four 5 6% whatever they
give you and then the remaining of your
15% go back go to a Roth IRA max it out
and if you still have percentages of
that 15% left go back to your 401k but
he has a Roth 401k situation which is
awesome Yep very good let's go to
Harrisburg Pennsylvania now where Caleb
is Caleb how can we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
you bet what's going on
today so I am
um I'm wondering what um what I should
start saving for first actually my wife
and I finish finish off paying off um
our debt there's a lot of things I could
save for and it feels overwhelming
because we don't make I gu a ton of
money and I'm just looking for any
advice you have so you paid off all your
debt does that include your mortgage or
no but we went we rent right now I'm 24
my wife's 25 married for about two years
okay congratulations when will you guys
be debt free they just
did well we have um no a little over
20,000 on we have a little over 20,000
on a student loan okay of hers left to
finish but once you pay it off you're
asking what to save for yeah what are
the things you guys are save for what
are y'all wanting to save
for well uh we we have two used cars
that have no payments mine's close to
200,000 I don't know how much longer
it's going to last I wanted to save for
a home I know we're supposed to save for
retirement we want to have kids and um
we make about 3,000 a month and so it's
an overwhelming prospect that I don't
even know where to go I have two months
of emergency expenses we built that up
before we started hammering the debt but
uh yeah that's great just I'm just not
sure where to go next yeah yeah I would
um I would bump it up to three months of
expenses after you pay off the debt and
that'll kind of cover that can be the
first goal is to get that fully funded
emergency fund um and then I would see
yeah where you are with your cars um I
think a car purchase is is always a
great thing to be saving for and kind of
just I would Kelly Blue Book your
current car and say okay how much is it
I wouldn't do it just because it doesn't
have just because it has 200,000 miles
obviously it needs to be in a place
where the repairs are getting so much
and you know it's starting to fall apart
on you then I would replace it but I
would I mean I would drive them as long
as long as you can and some cars
nowadays they they're built so well that
they do last and and it depends on the
type of car it may not be that expensive
do you have a line item in your budget
to Rachel's point for car
repairs yeah we put a little bit away
every month for maintenance and that's
done the well so far for tires and
anything that's come up okay that's
great yeah so I think um yeah saving up
for a car but that'll be that'll be a
faster you know goal to save for and
then Caleb after that so you got your
one more month of emergency fund to save
to get to your three months um saving up
a little bit for the car and then I
would look at baby
3B and that is where you save up a down
payment on a home so if you're a
first-time home buyer uh as low as 5%
you can go put down on a house but that
would be my next goal and you guys have
plenty of time for investing but I would
get those kind of buckled in and then
start saving 15% of your income into
retirement thanks for the call Caleb you
guys are going to do it it's going to be
fun Rachel Cruz thanks for co-hosting
what a great hour thank you Austin for
keeping the plane in the air this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
yeah
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life very
specifically in your money in your work
and in your relationships 8825 5225 is
the number
8825 5225 hey we'd love to hear from you
always fun to be sitting alongside my
good pal my friend I don't know if you
can call a lady of pal but I just just
my old pal Rachel Cruz known each other
forever um and we love love taking your
questions so let's have some fun let's
let's get some hope uh established for
you so you can move forward let's start
off in Philadelphia Pennsylvania uh the
city of Rachel Brotherly Love there it
is she used to make fun of me now I
think you've been paying attention to my
little my little quotes that's it just
you're so happy about it Melanie how can
we
help hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call I'm excited to talk to
you both well we're excited to talk to
you what's happening awesome so I'm a
little bit of a professional conundrum
so I love a
conundrum great word great word I'm I'm
currently working two full-time remote
jobs um that has been great for my
family kids in school and all that and
fortunate to find two you know remote
jobs um hold on a second hold on yes
this is fascinating I got to know do
both companies know about the other of
course not so you are a professional
polygamist are you aware of this can we
say I yes they're in two different melie
I am so sorry that you have to deal with
him no she's not offended she's not
offended at all I I expect Ken to give
me a hard time I listen not even doing
that I just wanted to say professional
polygamist because you've got you have
got two you got Sister Wives you got two
companies that you're working fulltime
time for and they don't know about the
other and I'm not even trying Sister
Wives knows about each other that is
fair you get my point it's a fun little
metaphor how are you pulling this off
how long have you pulled this off um
I've been doing it now for a year are
you exhausted and huh are you
tired I'm a little tired yeah I'm not
gonna lie full jobs tired yeah and
keeping them away from each other it's
like it's like having a mistress it's
exhausting so it's a lot of great time
management that's all I can say you must
be incredible so what kind of money you
knocking down so I'm netting 96 a year a
96 a year okay all right so what's your
question so I just been offered a a
different job that would cause me to be
hybrid three days in the office and two
days working from home um with a base
pay of
100K and with up to a potential you're
getting a 20 percent bonus of my base
pay oh wow and what has kept you from
saying yes to that offer well because I
technically would be netting
less um I guess you know right now my
husband and I bring home about 12 a
month and then if I take this we'd be
bringing home about
97 why would the net be less that's
that's not including the bonus though
yeah exactly and you're not cheating on
another company and thus risking getting
fired from one or
both yeah and and also I think
professionally the job that just offered
me this position would be a step up for
me professionally um great but I just I
I just I don't know I'm I just I'm a
little nervous about so it's the net
giving up with two remote jobs and you
know flexibility with the kids because I
do have like School AG children at home
let me let me ask you Melanie let me ask
you a real question and you've been a
great sport cuz Rachel thinks I'm being
mean I'm not I'm I'm not judging you I'm
just trying to coach you how long do you
think you're going to be able to keep
this up and then not find out about it
how long you think you got not very long
I mean honestly I think this is more
just to do the Deb snowball for you know
for my husband and I were a baby step
two I don't think you understand the
hold on a second melie I don't think
Rachel understands the concept she's
working two full-time jobs I hear that
be like you being a personality for
another company and they not know about
it it's it's it's she knows she can't
keep this up cuz she's going to get
found out and then she's fired yeah but
wouldn't it be like having a part-time
job you're just doing more hours it's
pretty much what it's like because they
are in two different
fields no no no okay hold on did just
for a point of emphasis here okay We're
Not Gon to get stuck on this but I gotta
help my friend Rachel and Melanie I
gotta help Rachel has to help me here no
Rachel has to help me no she doesn't
understand it once she understands it
Rachel listen here's what's happening
one company let's call it ABC is paying
Melanie yeah to work a full-time job yes
that's what 40 hours a week minimum
Melanie roughly yeah okay yes company
XYZ is also paying melon to work 40
hours a week and Melanie just tell us
how many hours you working a week for
both
companies
80 that's now I didn't see that coming
she's trying to get me on of
technicality I still think it's I think
it's it's unethical that they don't know
about each other yeah I could get the
secret yes and again not to judge you
Melanie CU there's no judgment it's more
protection so we've already covered D do
you get my no I always but in my head if
she's if she's working both I get the
secrecy right but if you're working both
fulltime okay I said I acknowledg that
she kind of had me on a technicality but
it's still dishonest and we still have
an ethical issue that she could get
penalized for but if one care about is
ABC company done cares that she's also
working for XYZ how do you know because
they don't know no but what if they're
not then it's not then in your book is
it okay if they're okay with it if
they're okay with each other 100% so
it's the secrecy that's bothering you
that they don't know about each other
it's not bothering me it's in a sense
that I think she's a bad it's just it's
it's risky for Melanie yeah I'm
literally playing defense lawyer for her
going I'm not going to tell you what you
did was wrong my job is to help you keep
getting paid and not get fired yes so
now the question is do I take this other
job which has a bonus and Beyond the 100
base right plus a path for growth
Melanie you said this is a job that's a
better play for you long term yeah Mel
it's a no-brainer now I'm not working 80
hours a week yeah now you're not working
80 hours a week and you're not cheating
on another company and and again it may
be a lifestyle shift because it's a
hybrid idea and and but maybe you get
into that and and it works and it's
great and you can you figure out the
logistics with the kids and your kids
are in school which is helpful um yeah
yeah or you you pan back a year from now
and say wow this is hard so maybe I go
back to LMO company you find another job
right but Melanie Melanie you do know
I'm on team Melanie right we love you
Melanie I do I do and I just wanted to
make sure that I'm not you're not kind
of shooting myself in the foot with um
$3,000 less that I be making yeah but
you're not but you told us you're not
including the bonus in that exercise so
I'm not so you got to put the bonus in
amortize that over 12 months and then
you start looking at the monthly quite
3,000 cuz you said 97 so it's yeah so my
point is I think it's all in all it's
not going to be that much of a
difference at all in the short term and
we know long term is better if you take
this new job and just for your own
benefits you're not working 80 hours a
week you're working 40 yeah that's true
that's true all right thank you so much
I appreciate your inut yeah Mel take the
job man you going to get out of jail
free here on this one I mean who by the
way this is a new trend she is not alone
there are millions of Americans that are
professional polygamist they are they
have two full-time jobs and they don't
know about each other and it is cheating
I don't care how you slice it I'm all
for you getting them paid but man you
can get fired and I makes me nervous you
know oh man woo this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
yeah
welcome back to the Ry show I'm kid
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me this hour
uh what do you think America that last
call it was really fun we we had a good
debate out we really did in the in the
lobby with the people that are here yeah
and make no mistake I want to say again
I got a t-shirt on it says team Melanie
I just don't want her to get fired and I
I feel like we got her a path to where
she's going to escape yes and nobody
hurt but again uh
it's fascinating what do you think of
Erica comment get out there on YouTube
and comment you think it's okay to have
two full-time jobs and both companies
don't know about each the don't know
thing just so everyone's clear they
don't know about it I I know I know I
know and I would say that is that's the
part for me that I'm like yeah you can't
I I mean you but if both companies are
okay with it I say get after it okay
there you go so yeah we're more on the
see we're more aligned I knew we were
this is America we're America right here
you think you're on two separate sides
in Act
in reality oh yeah if both companies are
okay with melie it's the secrecy I get
that then I'm like I get fantastic yeah
yeah yeah yeah go get you some money
because for some for some companies what
your position is you're a graphic
designer and you have these projects and
you got to you got to do it and if you
get it done in yeah 30 hours oh 60 hour
like you don't you're getting yeah
you're getting paid for that position
too you know what I want to get your
opinion on something really quick this
is fun I'm bring you into my for a
second okay career leadership work
listen listen listen listen the I think
the 40-hour work week is an Antiquated
metric anyway ah meaning I feel like
most people work more I think that and I
here's what I'm GNA say I love that
you're on this I think that if you look
at the world of work in Americans it's
either you work more than 40 hours or
you work less I don't think there's
anybody that's knocking out 40 hours let
me explain why if you work an 8 hour day
you're taking a lunch break which is
probably an hour y That's not eight
hours you're seven yeah so I'm just
going then you start we we know the data
don't look this up leaders the date on
how much time people spent on social
media during the work oh sure so now
you're way below 40 hours sure I'm just
calling it out to say to your point I
thought you made a good point it's about
the production yes not the time clock
that's right that's right y so you agree
I do agree with that
yeah the world of work is changing you
do know this oh gosh it's crazy have you
heard about four day work weeks have you
heard about the four-day school week oh
the school week there are school
districts now that are testing a 4 day
school week because of shortage of
teachers oh no way mhh so anyway I
digress the world is changing right in
front of us always Co did it too right
wouldn't you say I mean it it fast
forwarded everything could not boy we
are really in alignment today wow you
should keep making prediction we were a
car just it's it's it's it's great I
agree with you I think Co literally is
like a fast forward button unchange and
and I think too for people depending on
how they're wired it works like I have
so many friends that are hybrid I have
so many friends complely agree that want
to be in an office and they're like get
me out of the house there's no way I
could work from home some that are like
nope all I want to do I will only find
work for from home job I mean like yeah
and so it just get I like it because it
gives the variety to fit within your
life and you know I feel like a lot of
uh Jers we were talking about this oh
yeah with the a recent article but they
really see work as a means to an end
versus it being part of this life and
yeah it's fascinating and I get yeah I I
I see that so there you go so anyway
America we want you to sound off we love
it get in the comments section tell us
you what you think about Melody it's
always fun and and just for for the
record Rachel agrees with me so took her
a minute but we got her there you came
to my side a little bit was that what it
is whatever okay so I'm going to
capitulate again this is all I do I've
been married for 25 years I have a
teenage daughter I'm always giving in to
the women in my life what is going on
can I not be right
once
yeah so fantastic Tiffany rescue me from
this Tiffany's on the line in Houston
Texas what's going on
Tiffany okay so I actually wanted
y'all's input on something so me and my
boyfriend have been kicking around the
idea of you know renting or should we
buy like a mobile home and just it on a
piece of land no
never because there mobile homes are
around here for like 24,000 yeah and
guess what it's going to be worth in six
months after
that they go down down down down down
down down and value it's one of the
worst Investments you can make honestly
it's like buying a giant Cannonball and
and trying to hold it in the water it's
just you're going under you can't keep
the Cannonball up there it won't float
folks so I'm just telling you why it's
not it's not a good investment I'd
rather you rent and keep some stability
but not you know buy an asset that's
going downhill and don't buy something
together with someone you're not married
to as well Tiffany oh okay that's a good
point so don't put your NE don't put
both of your names on something I mean
all it needs to be have you have you
ever lived in a mobile home
yeah did you like it I well I was pretty
well too young to remember okay did it
have a redwood deck while I'm
asking um as far as I remember no it had
like a
um had the lighter wood that's a Sammy
Kershaw song I think it is but uh the
the point is is that you're trying to
figure out a way to cheaply live as
opposed to doing what it takes to live
smartly and what I mean by that is
you're going to going to buy an asset
that goes down and instead of people
think well I'm renting I'm throwing
money away and renting gives you options
and and renting gives you st stability
and so I just don't understand why you
would consider it other than it maybe in
your family or it's just something you
think is a normal thing to
do I actually had a couple people in my
family to buy them ex them up and then
sell them for like twice as much as they
put into it I don't believe that do we
have paperwork on
that yes they bought a mobile home and
sold it for twice as much who did they
sell it
to now that I don't know but they showed
me the paperwork they sold it for like
50,000 they only had about 20 in
it ah Tiffany how much do you make a
year um just me I make about 50 you're
50 okay that's great yeah so Tiffany
what I would do honestly yeah I would I
would rent do you what kind of debt do
you
have so I have like two credit cards how
much I have like $1,000 on them okay
collectively okay both of them have
$1,000 so so 2,000 in credit card debt
what
else no it's like one has 500 one has
four oh okay oh I'm sorry to get okay
okay okay perfect okay what
else
um I have like a payment to the electric
company that I have to make when me and
my ex-husband split up because my name
was on the utilities and okay he
couldn't keep it paid so I just had him
shut off okay um do you have a car
payment well my boyfriend does your
boyfriend does but you don't not in your
name no no okay so all you so okay well
you're you're in a good spot do you have
any money
saved I'm working on that one yeah
that's great that's great Tiffany well
well I think you know one of your first
goals is to get $1,000 saved I would not
combine anything with your boyfriends um
you want to keep finances separate when
you're not married um for many reasons
but one of them easily is just the legal
reason I mean if you put your name
together on something and then he's and
then you guys break up he stops paying
we get that call all the time you're
stuck with it so keep everything
separate um I my first goal Tiffany
would be to save $1,000 emergency fund
on your own uh with your money and put
that away and then cut up these credit
cards you could probably cut them up
today I would I would just get rid of
the credit cards and pay off that debt
after that ,000 is saved um and then
bump up your starter emergency fund of
to three to six months of expenses so
kind of starting to get you um a strong
Foundation financially for you where you
don't have payments you have some good
Savings in the bank and in the meantime
Tiffany then I would rent and again and
um on the on the lease or whatever I
would not I would not sign something
together let it be on in one of your
names and if something happens to the
relationship then that person is the one
who will live there the other person
will have to find somewhere else to live
but just don't merge your life and act
like you're married when you're not
because from a financial standpoint it
gets people in a lot of trouble so just
protect yourself in that Tiffany
financially but I would rent I would not
buy a mobile home we just see please do
your research on it yeah um it just it's
it's not a great investment long term I
would love for you to to own a home and
save up for a down payment here in a few
years all right we'll be right back
don't move this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Kim
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me this show
the phone number is8 825
5225 so glad you're with us let's go to
Fort Meyers Florida now where Tracy
joins us Tracy how can we help hi there
thank you for having me um my husband
was in a near fatal car crash a little
over a year ago oh my gosh so sorry is
he okay no thank you yeah God is good oh
wow um so he um he suffered from um with
paralysis um after at the at the
accident um and uh a month later he blew
he coated and he blew a stroke which
gave him brain damage so he was the um
the bread winner he was the bread winner
and so I'm just I'm sorry I don't I
didn't know I was going to cry you're
okay listen you you've been through a
lot that's a lot so anyway um we have a
22 and a 20-year-old um so um anyway all
that to say um I homeschooled the kids
and then um I was just working at a um
just a fast um fast food restaurant on
takeout um for about 6 months until the
ACT and I left and I never returned I
just started um a entirely different
part-time job um just about a month ago
and so um I don't make that much um it's
about 24 hours um it's part-time
obviously because I'm I'm with my
husband on Wednesdays and Thursdays in
Tampa and so anyway I I make roughly
about
1,700 um a month um to that um position
and so um I'm just I'm just wondering
what I can do to sustain um our house um
I want to be able to keep our home I'm
not quite sure if I'm going to be able
to but there is debt I have about
177,000 in credit card debt um our
mortgage is at a good rate it's uh
2.875% and our mortgage is 1518 um per
month so I mean those are very
comfortable numbers to me but when I
don't have income really flowing I do
have um a a stable amount in savings but
it's going to go I mean it's already
been dwindling for how much do you have
in savings um about 8,000 okay and and
so he's what have you been doing for
income since this
stroke um his um the truck that he um
totaled in the accident um I did get um
money back from that and I got scared um
I'm still paying on that as well um it's
like 180 something a month um I used to
basically um live on um and so I had
that and actually um you know um friends
um you know through different churches
um have were so gracious and they create
um my daughter actually Tracy did um did
you say because you're in Fort Meyers
and he's in Tampa yeah so Fort Meers is
our nearest um yeah City but yeah so how
far is how far is he from distance wise
how far two and a half hours okay and
he's there um obviously for medical
reasons yeah he's at the VA um in Tampa
is that so that means his expenses for
care are
covered um for now um until um they they
switch him to perhaps a longterm because
he needs 247 care okay will he be in
Tampa do you think he'll be there um for
the foreseeable future or will he be
coming back closer to you guys
um I don't I'm able to I I would rather
him stay there um I mean well actually
I'm torn about that um he would end up
in a nursing home probably if it would
you know be near us um there at my
question to you Tracy is I mean have you
thought about moving towards him if
he'll be there um you
know to to tell you the truth um I'm I'm
not quite sure um about that um for for
different reasons okay you know did he
have any retirement or any where were
you guys at on that I'd like to get a a
pretty high level picture of your
finances did he have retirement do you
guys have retirement what's that look
like no no it doesn't look like anything
because we just don't have that okay and
how old are
you I'm 57 okay how much is left on the
mortgage
Tracy um the current balance for the
mortgage is
233,000 the accident he was making
roughly like 4,000 something a month
okay take home pay yeah okay and how
much is on the truck how much do you owe
on the truck it's um to tell you the
truth I don't have the balance I've been
paying it for I mean he was already
paying on it so it been like two years
loan and it was only a $5,000 loan okay
so probably not much left on that okay I
want you I want you to find that today I
think as much um details as you can have
about your money
situation um usually kind of just the
more peace that you have because it
takes yeah all the guests work out so
you're able to see so I want you to find
that today if you can how much is left
on that truck loan um and then the
credit cards the 177,000 is that just
lifestyle is that to just to keep you
guys keep the lights on and throughout
this last year or did you guys have this
debt before the accident we had um some
of it before before the accident we
usually like to use cash but just got up
so I mean just out of no but I I also
used it um this past year you know just
for different things yeah for sure are
you are it feels like you have been
scraping by do you have a pretty good
budget you know exactly where the
money's coming and
going I do um but I just know that um
with with me being out of work and him
you know for over a year we really I
mean it just we took a big big hit no no
I get it but what I'm getting at is this
if you have a really good grasp of your
budget um then you should be able to say
all right I have to bring in this a much
a month so for instance I'm all I'm
doing is looking at the one bill which
is your mortgage is 1,500 a month and
you're making 1,700 a month so obviously
we've got to come up with a number where
you say I have to make and I'm just
going to put a number out there don't
don't freak out but if it's like like I
have to make 4,000 a month or 3500 a
month just to have some breathing room
okay um but in this situation Rachel I'd
love to see if maybe selling the house
getting a what's hard Tracy is I think
with these numbers as Ken was pointing
out that working
part-time longterm is not that that
can't be the solution it's not the
option so that's why I was asking about
you moving closer to him so that you
could work full-time and be close to him
and but those those decisions um they
have to yeah and that's what's so hard
Tracy and I commend you I can't even
imag I can't even imagine what you
walked through the last year and and
like you said and I feel like this is so
true for for a lot of women you know
they leave the workforce and they raise
kids and then you get put in a situation
and you think oh my gosh I have to go
back to work what am I going to do so so
Tracy I think it would be a um a good
goal for you just from a and Kin I'm
going to give an example here in a
minute J the job yeah you're the job
career expert Ken so you can speak into
this but but Tracy I would want you to
have a timeline soon you know it's um
it's February that and I don't know what
that looks like for you but where you
feel like okay I can now step step in
and get something more full-time and
even if it's a recep you know a
receptionist job somewhere or anything
that has benefits um that gets you a
stable good income um and use the use
the gifts that you know the talent
everything that you've that you have it
is marketable I'm like to run a
household and do what you're doing so
yeah let me give you a couple things
here okay so a $20 an hour job Tracy
okay 40 hours a week that's going to
gross you $3,200 a month okay that's a
that's a sizable raise that's at $20 an
hour okay and um you I'm giving you
examples you have companies like Walmart
uh Target um that are paying really good
hourly rates between let's call it $18
to $22 an hour you don't have to have a
ton of experience they want somebody who
they can count on and believe me they
can count on you they also give great
benefits and right now because of your
husband's long-term situation I'm not
just thinking shortterm when I give you
this advice I'm thinking long term you
can get in start getting some good
benefits right and and and maybe you
sell the house as an option and then
maybe you rent something maybe the 22
and the 20y old depending on what
they're they got their own life too but
maybe you get a roommate if your
husband's living we've got to do
everything we can right now to lower
your expenses as low as possible while
increasing your income Tracy to your max
of what you can do where you are right
now and then you can build out you can
get out of this hole you can pay off the
debt you can begin to invest you can do
this cuz you're going to have to Tracy
it's on you now and you can do it hang
on the line I want to get you with one
of our financial coaches that'll just
further help lay out a path let's also
give the full Suite every dollar Total
Money Makeover financial piece let's
come alongside Tracy in this situation
so sorry thank you Tracy for calling
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me and the
phone number to jump in is
88255 225 our scripture of the day comes
from Romans 129 don't just pretend to
love others really love them hate what
is wrong hold tightly to what is good
and uh our quote today from your
friend the Rachel friend makes the quote
today Candace Cameron bu is it oh is it
bu or bur buret or
bu do you know bu bu how I say itry C
that's right or not your integrity is
worth so much more than proving a point
or having the last word Ah that's a good
point great quote that one kind of gets
me because I tend to be the last word
guy you know I've had to learn in my
marriage to let Stacy have the last word
what's the quote they say it on Bluey uh
you can either be right or you can
either be right or have fun or something
I don't know shoot generally for me it
would be I can either be right or wrong
in Stacy's eyes and then that ends up
being
right you know happy wife happy life you
know just just just be wrong just be
wrong it's easier guys Tiffany is up in
Atlanta Georgia Tiffany how can we help
hi guys so about five years ago my
husband myself and my then 10-year-old
son were in a really really horrible car
accident oh my my son's yeah it was
really tough my son was in the
children's hospital for 40 days 28 in
the ICU oh my goodness I'm so sorry I
say he's great now he's a thriving like
15-year-old fresh in high school I say
he suffered the physical wounds but my
husband and I suffered the emotional
wounds we have done a lot of work but he
received a settlement from that accident
that after attorney fees and insurance
companies negotiated totaled about
$180,000 um I I yeah his dad and I are
financially like debt free stable um so
we have like college plans for him we
have no need to access that money so as
far as as we are concerned it's his
money and it's been invested for him um
it actually has had some growth it's
worth about
$215,000 now wow yeah so my concern well
it's kind of a twofold question that
money becomes his at 18 and so I'm not
sure there's any way I can legally kind
of Safeguard it to protect it from you
know decisions that 18yearold boys can
make other than we've tried to raise our
son to be fiscally responsible um and
then also what is the best
Avenue for that money do we continue
just to keep it invested in the market
or is there something we what kind of
fund is it in right
now um I'd have to go look I mean I
think it's in like kind of some mixed
index like it's it's we had our um
financial planner just invested okay
okay um yeah I I mean pretty significant
growth Yeah well yeah and the market you
know but you opened the account in his
name or do you guys have any authority
over it it seems like you have the
authority over it yes I I I do but from
what our legally was explained to us
that I'm the trustee it becomes his
money at 18 at 18 because it was the
lawsuit was in his yeah yeah for him I
don't know the answer to this Rachel but
could it could she as a trustee put that
in a trust put it within I don't know I
I would get legal advice I really would
I would sit with I would sit with one of
your we would send you to Smart Vestor
Pro I would get some legal advice on
this okay that would be the only thing
and I don't know the answer but I would
go okay as the
trustee I have authority over until the
kid turns 18 yeah so what decision so
this is the I don't have the answer but
I think I have the right question and I
want Rachel to correct me if this is the
wrong question but I would be asking
what can I do he and his father uh me
and his father do as his trustees with
that money to further protect it okay
and that's what I would look into you
may not be able to do anything I just
feel that there's got to be something
that you guys can do with that money as
the
trustees that would maybe push it out
maybe to maybe put it in a trust looking
I yeah somebody can answer that question
I wish I knew the answer but I would be
looking into that Rachel you agree yeah
because yeah and I think the goal you
know because it's amazing you guys have
college and all of it is that is he
doesn't touch it I mean the only reason
I would use that money if I were him and
you can kind of walk through this with
him which I know you guys probably have
had these conversations right but I'm
like you know if you're a 25-year-old
kid and you can buy a house and start
your life off DE for you know what I
mean like the things so would you put a
limit on it what age would you I'm
curious what age would you recommend
Rachel that he have access to these I
would like him to be out of college I
think that would be that would be ideal
right so 21 22 years old um and then he
what do you think Mom is that where your
head's at well yeah and his dad not like
I said we have a 529 plan for him we're
debt free we have a large net worth
ourselves and so he doesn't have to
worry about finances through college and
so ideally I think what we would like
him to do is to have it to start his
life with when he's done with grad
school or college he shouldn't have a
need for it before then that's right
that's right yeah I agree so to start
your life debt-free and then with a
chunk of money that you know has
continued to have compounded growth the
15 now 10 more years years it's wild
it's going to be some really nice money
y y Tiffany I think that's the question
to ask and and and and again and if you
can't protect it that doesn't feel like
overly controlling I mean if he's 32 and
you're like I'm still PR you know like
that's one thing but to get them out of
like yeah I feel like in college
everyone just doesn't make smart
decisions between 18 and 21 so it's like
oh yeah and I should correct myself for
these we have people listening I said 10
years I was thinking 25 give it 10 years
to grow and now he's you know he gets
out cuz and I'm not disagreeing with
either one of you ladies but there's
part of me that if I'm putting myself in
a situation I want him to come out of
college which you guys have been so
amazing to save up for him I want him to
get out there and and make it on his own
for a couple years before he comes into
this wealth uh yeah you see where I'm
going I'm not saying delay it to 35 or
that no right right but either way he
right but the point is is that's what
you got to figure out is how can you
extend it Beyond 18 if you can yeah yeah
until he's out of college would be my
goal um with it a lot of money to start
with but from a legal standpoint I mean
like like an upm account like all that
kind of stuff it does turn over you know
um but I would sit down and have a real
mature conversation and even show him I
mean I don't know how intrigued a
18-year-old would be at that point but
but pull up a investment calculator and
just say hey if you just you don't need
this money let's pretend it's not there
and when you're 22 23 24 like when you
can watch it um as it grows and at that
amount of money you're it's going to you
make a great Point Tiffany does he know
about the uh
215 he he he is aware of it he does know
about it and he's actually seen some of
the financial statements just because
he's a very intelligent 15-year-old yeah
and he has his own checking and savings
already because we've wanted to teach
him fiscal responsibility um and he's
actually a great saver and so he enjoy
seen this growth already that it's had
so we hope we're trying to instill those
values because we felt like that it's
better to to use this to help teach
lessons so that's why I ask I'm
wondering are you guys sitting down with
them going Hey so uh 215,000 it could be
this in three years or five years what
what are you thinking you do with it are
you having those conversations just to
see where his immature even though he's
a great kid he's still 15 uh where does
his head go on these things what does he
say he says to house one day yeah good
that's a great answer it's a great
answer he didn't say buy a Porsche which
isn't a bad idea but I'm point is is
like that's a pretty mature response so
I think talking with him about it and
letting him take some ownership before
he ever can touch it is an interesting
uh way to go about it Rachel yeah yeah
and and I mean like you know which the
judicial system did its work but I'm
like as a 10-year-old kid what you went
through like you know what I mean like
this money it's not that it that it
heals you know the wounds and the scars
and the memories of what happened by any
stretch of the imagination but for him
too to feel the the weight of what you
you know this is again I don't even I
hate comparing money to like a medical
situation but but we don't we don't want
to go and waste all of this because what
you went through this money is worth
more than that you know what I mean
great point that that feeling of what
you guys went through as a family I'm
like honor this money because it came
because of a horrible cost and we don't
want to you know and I would say the
same is true with inheritances when
people get an inheritance that you know
use that to to further that person's
Legacy and something that they would be
proud of you know so you kind of take it
in that vein as well but toy I'm so
thankful you guys are okay and that he's
okay and and great parenting by the way
you guys done a great job their your
financial situation is great so that's
what we want you to do go talk to people
who know the answers to that locally on
the ground and and you'll know what you
can do next Rachel Cruz great show thank
you my friend for always hanging out
great time want to thank Austin and the
team for keeping us on the air this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]